okay so welcome today
to my last webinar for udacity
actually on informational interviews how
to plant your seeds
and i'll get to what i mean by plant
your seeds later because
i'm a big advocate in being somewhat
intentional
in your networking and uh and in your
informational interviews
in the sense of thinking about this as a
dynamic
way for you to start creating
relationships
um potentially in the places that you
want to work
um okay give me a second
so i i will look at that i'll come back
to the chat in a moment but
uh just so you know a little bit about
me my name is andrea
i live in portland oregon
i have been a coach now uh starting i
think in 2014 or so
and before that had a long
a long history in hollywood actually uh
producing films
and working with people mainly writers
and directors
helping them see through their visions
i'm continuing this work i believe
as a coach actually in the sense that
i think one of the things i'm best at is
being able to help people share their
stories
and share their stories in a way that
puts their best foot forward
okay today we're going to talk about
uh informational interviews like what
what are they
basically why should we do them it's
something that has become definitely
more popular worldwide right now
not just because it's a it's a great way
to gather information
and to um start to build your network
but also because this last year
we're not having nice little networking
events that we can go to to meet people
um it's much more difficult to do
anything that's not
through this type of medium right now
and for the foreseeable future basically
um so as a
as a world in some ways
um we have been propelled forward
maybe 10 years in this past year as far
as
how we work you know and uh
not just the methodology of our work but
you know what what it work
looks like um and what
uh networking looks like as well
and so part of what i wanted to address
with this informational interview is
also that
this is absolutely possible to do this
type of networking now
and people are more accommodating and
open to it
than they ever have been before because
there aren't other opportunities
so easily to make an appointment and
come into somebody's office let's say
or to go to a networking event and
happen across somebody that might be
helpful to you
in your career so we are going to
uh talk about why do it uh elements
of an informational interview and um
i'm going to talk to you about like what
should be in the outreach letter that
you
uh share and we're also going to talk
about um
how you can pitch yourself really
briefly in that letter
um and so we'll we'll share that with
each other um
hopefully if we have enough people that
will be interesting and
then we'll do some follow-up and
questions and stuff
so first of all let me actually before i
ask you to ask the or to answer this
i want to know what uh i want to tell
you what an informational interview is
okay
an informational interview is
you are the interviewer okay
meaning that you are interviewing
somebody else to discover
things oh sorry things about their
job things about the workplace
things about the career that they have
pursued
it is an opportunity for you to ask
questions
and to learn and as such you're actually
doing the interview yourself as well
they are not interviewing you
so it is not a job opportunity i think
you're probably seeing
smaller part of the screen now but i
have to i have to redo this a little bit
um it is not uh
it is not a um i'm sorry it is not
a opportunity for them to interview you
or
and it is not a job um interview
so it is different that way so what do
you think
um and you can just add this in the chat
that's why i was just changing my view
right now
uh what do you think are uh
the most important thing about doing an
informational interview what do you
think you could get out of it
by talking to somebody that you have not
met before
um and who is in an area that might be
of interest to you
if you could just write down things in
the chat that would be great
because i'd like to see what people are
thinking i've also asked in the chat if
you could introduce yourself
so saying what where you're from and
what it is you're studying
uh sam thank you for for sharing that
everybody else that would be great if
you shared it as well chloe
did earlier and she's from glasgow and
uh is doing
data and uh has her phd
in physics right
learning from their experience yep
that's a good one you can speak up as
well or put it in the
put it in the chat what other what other
things might you get out of a
informational interview might what you
imagine you might get
guidance yep
anybody else
thank you for chiming up sight to saber
so you
are doing uh deep learning awesome
chart out a possible career path as an
example yes i think that that's a good
idea
hi hitesh nice to see you again
and ux designing so the question that
we're all answering right now basically
is
what do you think is the number one
reason to do an informational interview
for you
i think all of those reasons are are
good
and and i encourage you to to engage
because i think we learn from each other
um i think actually the number one
reason
why i would do an informational
interview
uh is not
it is something that may be a little
more intangible
but is uh ultimately what matters
which is developing relationship
expanding the relationships that i have
in a field that i believe i want to be
in
and deepening those relationships as
well
learning learning about the other person
and deepening those relationships
um so i'll talk about this later but i i
think that oftentimes the mindset
that we need to have is definitely
one of curiosity
okay so talking about other benefits of
an informational interview
getting first-hand relevant information
from people who are professionals in the
area that you're in
can somebody let me know are you seeing
this properly i hope so i'll put it back
and present for right now actually
so i think that'll be fine um getting
first-hand relevant information about
the realities of the workplace
finding out about career paths as you
said that
you may not see like by looking at
people's linkedin profiles you get some
sense of their career path
absolutely but you may not know some of
the variety
of how things happen so for example
when i was uh we were in a conversation
today
that that i thought about it in a
different way
now which is i often tell people like it
is easier for you
if you want to change your job to
look in the company that you're in
already and figure out how you can move
departments for example in that area
doing an informational interview for
example with people
in the department that you want to go to
learning what kind of skills they're
looking for
what where any gaps might be whether
you are a good match for that or not as
far as the where what skill level you're
at now
do you need to go any further or not
and um what is relevant about
doing that sort of internal
informational interview
is that it often makes it easier for you
to
to um start to take a different career
path
that is hard to read oftentimes in
people's
profiles and it's something that
it's good to hear if they're sharing
those sorts of ideas with you that they
started in one area and they moved to
another area
and how did that happen for them
in reading a profile you don't
necessarily
understand the details of how somebody
moves or somehow how they develop their
career path
and so this is by having this sort of
conversation with somebody
you can get into some of the nuance of
how they're moving um in their career
how they're moving
up or over in their career and how
that's worked for them
uh insider knowledge obviously that can
be a good to understand
as i said skills that are really valued
at the company or it might be even
lacking at the company
um what it's like to work there you know
this is
an opportunity very much for you to
listen
also so i think that
you know in choosing how to do
informational interviews
that one of the first things that you
should think about doing is
creating a what i call a hit list
basically
a hit list of the types of companies
that you think
you would like to work for
and trying to develop relationships
through informational interviews at
those companies
so this is what i mean by laying seeds
so if we look at the universe
as um i i think there are
40 companies out there that i think i
might be a good match for
it might be interesting to me it might
be
that they're a you know a caring company
that they
they care about humans uh i've done my
research
this this is the world that i think i
want to join okay
notice that all of this is not these are
jobs that are offered right now and
these are the jobs that i'm going for
the way i look at it is that's a very
passive way of looking for work
okay that's a very reactive way to do it
this in a way is a more um
more calculated and more proactive way
of doing it
in the sense that okay i'm defining the
universe
the universe are these 40 places that i
think
i could be a match for from the research
i've done
and now let me start laying
relationships
in each one of these places maybe i
already have a relationship there
that's great but maybe i don't have a
relationship yet and if i don't have a
relationship yet
at that place let me see who it is i
have the most in common with
who can i reach out to to see if they're
willing to do an informational interview
with me
ultimately to see do i want to keep this
this company on the list or not maybe
i will replace it maybe what i hear
between the lines when i'm
doing this interview and hearing from
this person is
wow they're unhappy here and
the company isn't very nice and
and it's nice that they're doing this
interview with me and i've learned
something about their career and
all this but oh my gosh that that that
company is now off the list this is not
the place i want to go
so you're not um you're interviewing
them about themselves you're
interviewing them about the company
but you know part of it is that you're
also sort of
doing reconnaissance you know is this a
place i might want to go
and i want to continue to pursue in some
fashion or not
i'm saying that this is a good way to
organize yourself because
it's a lot of effort to do an
informational to get one set up
and so i'd rather you spend the effort
with the educated guess in mind
that this might be ultimately a place
for you to go
rather than happenstance
guesswork oh i like that person's
profile okay
i don't know where they work i don't
think i would ever want to work there
but let me
let me develop a relationship with this
person
that can also work i'm just saying i
think it's good to be a little more
calculated about it a little more
um hopeful that the reason you're
choosing this person
is that where they are
or the type of position they're in also
is is something that you aspire to
okay so in setting up uh
an interview first thing to do is
research
we want to pick the people so so first
of all i already said
i think that you should choose
um choose people by calculating places
that you think or institutions or
companies that you think you might be a
good match for
so that's part of the research the next
part of the research
is looking into the people that are
working at
that company let's say and
identifying the people that you have the
most in common with
it could be that you both like
cake baking or soccer or that you've
both taken udacity classes or you both
went to the same university
or that you um that they've written a
paper that you
read and that you thought hey this is
this is a clever
person i actually would like to know
more about them they're
interested in some of the same ideas
that i'm interested in
and i can tell that way because of uh
things that they have published over
time maybe you're the
part of the same group of people you're
both in a data analyst group maybe or
like the bertelman scholarship
group you know something that you have
in common what we find in reaching out
to people with informational interviews
the more that you make that clear to
begin with the more that you say
hey you know joe i know joe let's let's
talk basically they whatever the joe is
um that there's there's some similarity
there the more likely they are
to respond they
and i'm gonna go into other elements not
not just yet but um
other elements that need to be there as
well but
identifying the people that you want to
do preparing for the interview that has
to do with
establishing what type of questions you
would like to ask
and also being able to present yourself
in you know a sentence or two okay
because this interview is not about you
you do need to be able to
you know introduce yourself speak about
yourself at the beginning of the
interview but it really is about letting
them
them take over basically asking
open-ended questions so that they
um can talk about themselves they can
talk about business they can talk about
things
and for you to learn um when i say
initiate contact
linkedin yes that's an excellent way to
go about it
the other possibility is sending uh
emails to their their work email
uh that is not as preferable
i would say um just because
we don't wanna one it can be lost
pretty easily to um it
it's not it's a little more of an attack
than you want it to be
you know linkedin is set up as a
networking platform basically
so if they are engaged in linkedin at
all part of them wants to be networking
at least part of them wants to be
networking but their
work email address is um a little like
walking into their home
and and so if you cannot find another
way to get a hold of this person and you
think oh my gosh but they're like
they're exactly who i would like to
learn from then i would go to the work
email address if you can't do linkedin
but i would prefer
uh choosing linkedin you conduct the
interview
and then a very important part of it is
follow-up and this is true
when you think about networking in
general also not just informational
interviews
and what i mean by that is if you are
going to a networking event
i think it's always important to set
certain goals as to
what it is you want out of it how many
people do you want to meet what kind of
people do you want to meet
and decide even in advance how am i
going to follow up with all of these
people
am i going to set up coffees with them
am i going
to listen carefully to what
it is we talked about in the
informational for example
and maybe share articles that are
relevant to them
and that they might find interesting or
maybe something strange
came out of this interview and and you
all discovered that you both
love um curling and that's like
you both happen to love this sort of
thing follow up with this
share some information about the curling
this is about relationship
remember to begin with and the way that
you deepen relationships
is you invest you invest in the other
person basically you invest in the
things that you have in common
you you figure out how to follow up not
around need
but around giving potentially and around
um continuing to establish the things
that you might have in common
okay um so i want to try this with you
all
uh and i need to i guess
do this in a different way so that i can
see the chat
uh give me one second there okay and
uh you can't see the slides and i didn't
know that you can see the slides okay
sorry because i couldn't see the chat
myself oh technology is wonderful
you can hear me though okay everybody
right
uh give me one second and i'll share the
slides again
i don't know why it went away
um
huh i'm not sure why it is not sharing
right now
i
can see you all now
and give me one moment and let's see
if that shares the screen
can you all see that now
yes i can you can okay sorry that that
uh
went away this is the slide that you
missed i actually walked through
many of the aspects of the slide so you
can see that at this point
sorry i'm having a little bit of tech
tech challenges um but i want to go into
this one actually
uh
that was the last slide if you missed
that these are the
the steps that we want to keep in mind
research identifying people
preparing for the interview initiating
contact
and conducting the interview and doing
the follow-up
so one thing i would like to try to do
for each other is in the chat
i would like to see how you would
introduce yourself to someone
and so we're talking about a sentence
maybe um
you don't need to sell yourself hard to
this person
you just need to sell um
you know something about yourself
basically um
we should assume that they have your
information on linkedin so they know
where you're from
they know a little bit about you but in
a sense you want to give
a summary um and that's why i thought it
would be fun if you all introduce
yourselves to each other in this way
um a one sentence summary of who you are
and uh and where you're going
basically what what you're imagining
that you're going to be doing
um so it may be that you're turning into
a ux designer
or you you know you come from a
background in something else and
designing but you're you're really
passionate about ux design
and that's what you would like to share
about yourself um
but if you can do that in the chat and
i'm just wondering if people are seeing
the chat since i am not seeing the chat
quite yet
um that would be fabulous
so unmute yourself and let me know if
you are seeing yourself in the chat or
not
and we don't have to do it in the chat
you this is something that you could
actually
do in um we can speak out loud as well
now i can see the chat
okay that's better
and thank you sam for letting me know
that there was a problem there
so
i'm going to put a little uh example in
the chat right now
of how i might in a very brief sentence
introduce myself
again with the assumption that they have
my
linkedin profile they can see it
basically but
i want to give them just a little bit of
something about myself
does anybody want to share in the chat
okay since i'm not seeing anybody share
we will move on
and i'm going to give you some
examples of questions that you might
think of asking okay
i these are
some of these are very general questions
in the sense of
you know how did you begin your career
you know what got you into it what got
you excited about being in your career
um to begin with these are good
open-ended questions okay you're not
looking for questions that
can you can give a yes or no answer to
basically
you want them to be able to talk about
themselves people love talking about
themselves
first of all so the main thing is you're
trying to get them to talk about
themselves
um and trying to get them to share
things um
and look for the recommendations so
let's say that you're just beginning in
a ux
career and that's that's the area that
you're going in
um what do they think was most important
to them
in having a ux career what what sort of
preparation was most important to them
what was most relevant to them how did
they get their job what
how did that come about um that might
teach you something a little bit about
the industry
i just want to give you a weird example
of that
um so you have some sense basically
there was this guy that i
i worked with who his interest was
in robotics and and agriculture
and uh how robots were used in
agriculture and he found through doing
informational interviews and and finding
out
you know from people that were working
in that field like how did they network
where
where did they meet um how did they get
their job
how did they network to it in some
fashion another and what he discovered
anyway was that there was this slack
channel out there
and the slack channel was specifically
for farmers
who were interested in technology and
how technology could better
run their farms and that this
guy that he was interviewing introduced
him to the slack channel
and now that's become one of his biggest
areas that he
does interviewing as interviewing does
uh networking in
um only because he discovered that that
way
so that those are some of the sort of
questions that i would ask also if
you're entering into a new career
is where do they network themselves you
know what
what are the networking groups that are
a part of that maybe you should be
joining and be a part of as well
here are some of these others other
questions that are interesting what
skills abilities and personal attributes
are essential to success in your job in
your in this field
so having them do a little reflection
for you and
listening for skills that you have and
that you don't have or that you want to
be working on that might be
relevant um one of the questions
i also want to to have
let me i should check again if you're
seeing this since i don't know
for sure and i keep having this i mean
i'm scream sharing it says okay
so um i want to know for example
who might you suggest that i speak to
next i'm gathering information now i'm
trying to figure out where i
where i want to go next and uh
next best steps for me right um
who would you suggest that i speak to um
would you mind if i used your name if i
reach out to that person um those are
all things that you can
absolutely you know ask at the end of
the meeting so you're not asking for a
job ever at the end of an
informational interview but you could
ask for the next steps
so follow up i
part first thing to do keep records of
what it is
um great thank you very much for
christina
for sharing that um keep records
keep records of what their answers were
okay
or things that you realize oh my gosh
that wasn't a question that
i didn't quite get the answer to that
question that i have
or i'd like to know more about that so
you know right away and this is a good
thing to do by the way in interviews
also
um when you're interviewing for a job
great
right afterwards to write down what were
the questions
that they asked me how did i answer them
how might i do it better
the next time before you forget because
you'll forget fast
um but just like with that one write
down what it is
what were your big takeaways here from
this conversation
what did you learn what it what other
questions that it opened up that you
didn't even realize you had
um and that maybe you want to follow up
on with this person or maybe this will
better inform you for the next one
definitely send a thank you note
um this was a gift
someone has given you and you asked for
it but it's still a gift
and you should be thankful for that
depending on how
strong the connection was you might want
to give
a little gift um my cousin
who's uh 25 years old
and works at a big
advertising agency and uh
is looking for different work to do and
she did an informational interview at a
company with a man that she met
at a like a resort sort of thing or
something like that
um when they went away last year and uh
did an informational interview with him
and sent him a little starbucks card
afterwards
as a thank you because he spent a good
amount of time they wound up speaking
for an
hour on the phone he wound up
introducing her to
someone else in the company that would
be more appropriate for her to talk to
about um possibly getting hired and
getting more information
he was really generous and really
invested
basically in this conversation and so
her follow-up
you know followed suit it wasn't just to
thank you very much
it was a thank you thank you that was
really nice for you to invest in me like
that
and here's a little something for you
too so
this is not about a big gift at all okay
i'm just saying that
if if you feel like the conversation
warrants it and it was a very
generous giving um that they gave you
think about what you'd like to give back
okay again remember this is about
relationship
and it can make a big impression okay
when you do something like that and you
appreciate people appropriately
another part of this keep in touch with
the person
and keep developing this relationship
share things when it's not about
necessarily what you need right now or
that you're looking for work or anything
like that
or that there's now a job just that
there's a job open at their place and
would you put them up for it
um would they put you up for it excuse
me but keep in touch with a person find
ways to
um share things that you discovered you
have in common
or maybe ask for their input on
something
i don't let the relationship
die when the when you hang up on the
phone
okay um do a follow-up
okay hold on one sec
let's move forward okay it didn't move
forward
okay so what you should be prepared for
in this interview
first of all prepare the questions in
advance of course
um and and have them be flexible have
more questions than you do
think you have time for um but you want
to be able to
uh have this be a focused conversation
basically
and uh a limited time
so in respect the person's time if you
have asked for 20 minutes of your time
stay within that
and if it feels like they would like to
continue speaking and this
this conversation is going very nicely
regardless at the 20-minute
mark now i'm sharing again of course
okay there
uh regardless at the 20-minute mark i
be like you know i would love to
continue this conversation but i respect
your time
and i said it was 20 minutes and i'm i'm
i i thank you so much for meeting now
maybe we should wrap it up now if
if you don't have any other time okay um
you know give them a choice
at that point don't just assume ah they
were going let me do this
it shows that you you respect their time
if you you honor the fact that
this is what you asked for you asked for
20 minutes they agreed to 20 minutes
and if anything goes beyond that
basically you're re-upping the um
the agreement um that now it can
proceed beyond that and it's good to get
agreement on that sort of thing
as opposed to just letting it go and
remember again you're basically in
charge of the interview
okay um things you also want to
add is you know you want to
ask if there's other people that you
should meet and that you know
what they suggest that way your resume
yes of course you should have that ready
and you should have ready to email them
right away i know people who've done
informationals where the person has been
like yeah show me your resume right away
they showed the resume and it's like and
then they had all sorts of comments on
what should be done with the resume to
make it better
for the type of work that they were
doing so
do have that ready you don't know when
you might run into someone who's going
to take a deep interest in you
and want to move you forward in some
fashion and be your advocate
and you want to be able to give them all
tools
at that point and be ready for it
um i wrote down uh
prepare relevant stories i think you
should just
be like an interview for a job always
have ready
stories that you want to share about
yourself that are
clear stories that have a beginning or
that you can talk about the situation
you can talk about the sort of actions
that you took
and you can talk about the results you
got that's a story
okay a story has a beginning middle and
end to it
and you all have stories and you all
have uh things that might be worthwhile
sharing and that are indicative of who
you are
this is an opportunity potentially to
share
maybe one of those stories if they ask
you about yourself
in more detail okay be prepared to
deliver
a story if that's the case not
oh i don't know i i there's nothing
about me
you don't need to know anything about me
this is not an answer okay
you want to be able to share a little
bit about yourself
so you know things to get ready and to
think about
the questions have your resume ready
just in case
your introduction and
also a story that you want to share
you know if if it comes up that you can
share about yourself that you feel
comfortable
that is indicative of you in some
fashion
the other thing is just yeah do this in
in a formal environment in the sense of
uh don't do it lying down on your couch
um
and you know with your feet up and and
talking that way or to starbucks with
all the noise and so on
you know do it in a way that it's just
it's quiet
focused and you're giving them your full
attention
and there's a bit of respect going on in
that fashion as well
okay so let's see if i can get the chat
back again
i'll give me one second here
okay um any
questions at all about this and one
thing i'm curious about people and you
can please unmute yourself
and you can talk that's fine i
you know have any of you actually done
an informational interviews before
i would love to know that and and have
you all share with each other
what type of experiences you might have
had with informational interviews
harvina hi andrea hi
thank you so much for the presentation
that was very insightful
good i'm glad i'm sorry if it was coming
in and out but i'm glad that it was
no worries thank you uh so
the reason why i joined uh to this
webinar
is uh because last year i did
informational interviews and that was
like my first experience
um and i think i conducted about 100
interviews
over the summer wow listen to you
good for you that was pretty intense and
uh
it took a lot of time a lot of energy a
lot of preparation but a lot of
learning during that time i made a lot
of mistakes
and then i learned through those
mistakes um
and and i agree with all the points that
you have mentioned
um i guess my question is one
usually a challenge i i don't want to
say it's an issue or problem but
challenge
i usually face yeah is usually following
up
and keeping my keeping in touch with my
networks
and deepening those relationship
afterwards
i feel a little bit intimidated like
to send articles or to send resources
i feel like i'm burdening them with you
know
extra information uh it would be very
helpful if you can
you know narrate on that i have a
question for you parveena
if um a friend of yours sends you an
article
that is you they think would be
interesting to you
do you consider that a burden
uh no usually i i like that that the
person took the time
and thought about me and and thought
that i would be interested in that
article
parveena yes you're not special
i mean in the sense that um
that's going to be their reaction too
they're not going to be oh my gosh
parveena how dare her take another
minute of my time
by forcing me to open this article all
about curling even though i love
curling how dare she send this to me
that's not going to be anybody's
response
so so one thing you know i would just
say parveena and
listen i would love for you to share
more of your experience of doing
doing the 100 interviews but as far as
the
follow-up goes and as far as deepening
relationship goes
you know we're human beings off
however different we may be um
there's also a lot that is very very
similar
if your reaction to somebody reaching
out to you and saying hey
i haven't talked to you in a month but i
just saw this thing i thought about you
um i thought you might enjoy this boy
for me at least i would have a really
positive impression of you
and that would deepen our relationships
and that would make me think ah
parveena yeah i want to keep her on my
radar right
my reaction would not be i
i don't i don't you know how dare she
remember this
about that and
you know and infiltrate my day like this
so you know some of this is i don't want
to say it's common sense because it's
not necessarily i think that it is
um i think that creating and maintaining
relationships can be challenging
and they take effort to do um one thing
that i
i didn't mention in this and i want to
um
and i did want to talk about is
mindset wise not just for informational
interviews
but for other networking situations as
well
something to keep in mind is
not the mindset of i need i want
i i need i have to get this out of this
person
this piece of knowledge or this
connection or
that's all a very basically greedy way
of um approaching a new relationship
the two mindsets that i think are
helpful
in uh being able to conduct an intro
informational interview and approach new
relationship in this way
is one curiosity
and two service
how might i help this person what might
i share with this person that might be
interesting
for them how can i be of service
it may not be around the area of
specialty that you're talking about it
may be that
you're from glasgow and they're from
edinburgh and and
they want to know what the the coolest
place to live in glasgow is
right um that it may be
totally unrelated but something that you
can share with them
because you have that sort of thing in
common
so praveena don't um
[Music]
first of all don't worry that you're
somehow hurting somebody by sharing
information
um you're not and you're not uh
the the they can always ignore it if
they want to
right and just say yeah you know i don't
care about
about curling anymore i don't really
care that you sent this to me
they're not going to have a negative
impression of you that you thought of
them
it's rare enough that we think of other
people
any other question thank you thank you
andrea for your answer that makes a lot
of sense
certainly and parveena by the way any
other insights that you had in doing a
hundred of these
these in um
i guess all my interviews that i was
able to get
was through my networks so that's
how important networking is
and if you haven't for all the
participants who are in this webinar i
would like to say that if you haven't
been networking
please do it because um
this is the way how you can maybe find
your future boss
or potential boss um and
uh of course like my um
why i was doing informational interview
was i was looking for a job
and uh yeah and uh so that was my main
reason but then when you start
informational interviews
you should kind of forget about it and
be less selfish and be like very curious
about the other person
and try to learn from them
and and please don't ask them for a job
yeah yeah in your first interview this
is the biggest mistake
so um yeah i guess that's
overall that's what i learned from
informational interviews
fabulous are you working now
uh currently i'm pivoting to data
analyst role so no i'm not
working right now i'm taking classes
with udacity and really focusing on
um you know starting a new career in a
new field
and i guess i have one question if
that's okay
um i was wondering i'm i'm right now
i'm on my second month of of my courses
and i was wondering should i should i be
doing uh
informational interviews networking
right now or is it better
or is it better to do it after courses
i don't think there's actually one of
the things that i really recommend for
people that are in
school for example in in college or in
or in
graduate school is
in essence by the time you graduate
all of those informational interviews
should be over already
um because by the time you graduate
that's when you're actually looking for
work
and now that's when you want to actually
call on your networking
you know people to to help place you
so you want to lay all those seeds in
advance
so i would say absolutely there's no
reason for you to wait
for that this is part of you um stepping
into a new career
doing a pivot and learning more about
data science and that may inform
how you're at actually learning things
as well
and what you focus on or what you
realize you know in this class it
doesn't really cover
visualizations you know well enough and
visualization seem to be a really
important thing
um for the type of data work that i
would like to do
how can i better improve my skills in
that area or what sort of things should
i publish in that area
and you might not know that making up
what that is
but you might not know that without
doing an informational interview and
seeing
oh my gosh they put so much value on
these visualizations being wonderful
stories
i need to work on those skills
so i wouldn't wait yeah thank you andrea
thank you any other questions from
anybody
that informational or any worries about
doing it as well
i wanted to to say i just wanted to
share one one other story
which is um a woman i know who
was living in japan for years and who
was moving back to the united states
and all she knew was so she had been
teaching english in japan
all she knew was she wanted to work in
environmental stuff
in the united states so she did exactly
what parveena did
she had like a hundred of these
informational interviews
all over the place trying to figure out
what what area it was she really wanted
to go into
and making connections etc
when i met her she she was telling she
told me this story
she's like i'm working now with one of
these people i did this inter
informational interview with and i'm in
charge of
all of the greenways in portland of
where people
uh use their bicycles and stuff so
absolutely related to that area
and she had reached out to somebody in
that department who is now her boss
but this this happened like soon
afterwards basically not
out of the conversation initially but
um absolutely this is a way to open up
career paths for yourself as well
that's it of my story chloe did you have
something you wanted to add um
yeah so basically i've never actually
heard of informational interviews before
this seminar
um and i was wondering how would you
land an informational interview
well so what what so what
you want to do is you want to write a
letter this is not a phone call
you want to write a letter preferably on
linkedin
where you're reaching out and you're
saying
hi joe this is what it you know i
noticed your profile
you're working at a great company that
i've interested in
uh i've noticed also that we've both
taken udacity classes together
you know similar udacity classes and i'm
making this transition to
x i'm turning from being a physicist
to being a data scientist
i would love to have um
20 minutes of your time uh perhaps over
zoom
or or google meet or one of these
formats basically
uh over the next couple of weeks
the one thing i would add to this letter
also which is just
me but i think it's a good effective
thing and parveena you can
chime in also is uh
i like to say also at the end of it and
i will follow up with you
in a week let's say or in two weeks
the reason why i say it's good to say
i'm going to follow up
are three reasons one guilt
basically you see this you know oh
chloe's coming back to me again
maybe i should respond to her before she
comes back to me
provides a little bit of guilt
potentially two
when you do follow up and use and you
write
joe again and say hey joe just touching
base again
would love to know if you have 20
minutes you know to meet with me
uh regarding your career and x company
thanks chloe okay um
then when you followed up you are being
clear that you are professional
you're a person of your word you said
i'm going to follow up i followed up
right then if they don't respond after
that
and yes people will not respond people
do not read their email people do not
look on linkedin people's mothers dies
people
all god knows what happens with people
okay but
not everybody responds it has nothing to
do with you not everybody responds
if at that point you followed up you
said you were going to follow up you
followed up
you don't hear anything from them now
you know okay
i'm done with joe and i'm now moving on
to susie
and susie works in this place we don't
have as much in common but i'm going to
write her and talk to her about what we
do have in common and do exactly the
same thing again
so in a way mentally it gives you a
break you you understand ah
joe i wrote show i followed up with joe
joe didn't respond done with joan
next person so it gives you that sort of
break in mind
is does is that clear chloe yeah yeah
thank you very much
you're welcome anybody else have any
other questions
how would you suggest uh us to keep uh
in touch with the
network that let's say we had an
informational interview and
how to keep uh how to not forget about
each other
yeah so um
to keep it i think there's two questions
in there okay
and uh one of the questions is
how do i it's sort of like sales uh
how do i keep myself organized so that
five months don't go by and i go oh my
gosh i was supposed to
talk to chloe and i forgot about chloe
what you can do is let's say let's say
like with
what parveena did she reached out to a
hundred people
maybe 25 of those people are people that
she actually wants to keep in her life
and they are people that are she
considers a value that
she feels like they had a good
connection feels like
i you know i want to continue this you
know i want to
i want to see where this goes um those
25 let's say
because not everybody do you want to
deepen your relationship with okay but
that's that's for you to judge okay but
for the ones that you do
um i would put those 25 i would decide
when i want to follow up put it in a
calendar and on a
sort of consistent basis
do follow-ups so if you want to do it a
month from then
for the first one and then three months
just put it in a calendar
and trigger yourself to remember hey
you know something i haven't talked to
chloe in a while
uh you know and i saw something recently
that i thought
she would like let me let me share that
now and if you hadn't thought about
chloe then
in your calendar that it reminds you
hey follow-up time chloe then you can
think about it also
reach out and maybe just see how she's
doing or say hey i
noticed the new news from your company
that you all are
trying this new venture congratulations
on that that's wonderful
whatever it might be it doesn't have to
be necessarily you giving of
like i have to figure out the perfect
article to send to chloe before i
reach out to her it could be just sort
of
checking and seeing what's what's going
on and um
touching base with the person and
basically
does that help tigran yep thank you so
much
you're welcome some of this is is
you know listen networking to some
degree to some degree
is sales what you're selling is yourself
and in selling yourself you want to
remember to keep yourself in front of
people and present in some fashion
and mainly what i'm doing is something
yet if you think about selling yourself
it's actually kind of uncomfortable
but if you think about giving to people
and keeping that as part of what you're
selling
um that can be a much much more
comfortable place to be
okay so if there are no other questions
one thing before we go i'd like you to
just look at is
in the chat um several people have been
generous
to share their uh linkedin profiles and
would like to connect with you
for you all to connect with each other
and i just want to show you one thing
that's
easy to do so you should know if you
click the three
buttons on the right side across from
everyone
in the chat you
see the thing that says save chat
if you click that the chat will download
into your computer so that you can then
go to these linkedin profiles easily
and connect with each other in some way
is if anybody has not
shared their linkedin but would like to
start connecting with the people that
are in this room please do so now
before i close the room and that's a way
to grab everything
easily basically is the safe chat
thank you very much for joining me today
i'm sorry there was a little bit of
technical
problems as we went along but um i hope
that
you will start to incorporate
informational interviews
into the way that you network and into
the way that you
start finding opportunities and
knowledge as you're on this path
to becoming professionals in whichever
field you are in
um thank you very much it was very
insightful
oh good i'm so glad
[Music]
and i just got your email about sharing
it to
uh gh2 gen i will save the chat as well
and i'll send that on to you a little
later
thank you so much andrea have a nice day
take care thank you
[Music]
thank you have a good one great take
care of them
thank you adria you're welcome
okay i'm gonna close it out now take
care